uh we cannot be distracted
by donald trump's antics from the real
crises
and real responsibilities and duties
that we have
the virus police killings protests
evolving into chaos and violence
removing trump must be done
but trump is very aggressively trying to
distract us i already told you some of
the ways
earlier and the latest is trump tweeting
that he will be designating
antifa as a terrorist organization
donald trump of course announcing this
on twitter saying quote the united
states of america will be designated
designating antifa as a terrorist
organization there's a few different
things to talk about here
antifa is a militant left-wing movement
that stands for anti-fascism
antifa okay that's where the name comes
from
antifa is not centrally organized it's a
sort of umbrella
designation antifa i see is more of a
strategy than a group of people per se
and sometimes they do violent things
that i vehemently oppose
i have been endlessly critical of many
of the tactics
employed by individuals organizing under
the umbrella of antifa
it appears though that what donald trump
is trying to do here
is not actually constitutional in
designating them
a terrorist organization the united
states state department
has a list of terrorist organizations
they are foreign
antifa is not foreign antifa is a
domestic
group even more importantly if donald
trump were to designate
antifa as a terrorist organization they
would lose
some first amendment protections which
apply only to foreign terrorist
organizations so
understand that this is part of the
framing by trump and william barr
that the recent protests and unrest are
merely
left-wing anarchists looking to do
violence and so chaos
now to be clear there is no shortage of
anarchists
all over the political spectrum doing
protesting many
with ulterior motives but there is also
plenty of right wing astroturf
there is police escalation by way of
haphazard pepper spraying
uh shooting at media etc and this entire
story of
this is not genuine anger
and frustration with policing in america
or whatever else
these are provocateurs coming in from
outside
that is being used to single-handedly
devalue the complaints and concerns
that the protesters have and we can't
fall for that
but this claim from donald trump
that he will be designating antifa as a
terrorist organization
it's a political statement it is not a
law enforcement statement it's really
important to understand that
and it doesn't appear to be a legal
statement either trump really cannot
designate a domestic group a terrorist
organization
it would deny them their first amendment
rights it would also deny them due
process
and it is likely unconstitutional and
it's not something trump is going to be
able to do
he may not even really try because
understand the state department's list
of foreign terrorist organizations
you just can't put antifa on that list
but he said it on twitter
and that's the whole point that's the
big picture here this is another attempt
to distract
we must keep our eyes on the ball trump
has failed on coronavirus
more than a hundred and five thousand
have died fifty or sixty percent of
those deaths
that those deaths could have been
prevented by a two-week
earlier request from trump for a
50-state stay-at-home order
and actual testing capacity on that note
i don't want to get you to something
boring but understand
trump's tweeting about designating
antifa a terrorist organization
we still after four months aren't
testing 500
000 people a day in the united states we
still after four months aren't at the
absolute minimum testing we need
to really look at reopening the country
we have national unrest with protests
violence looting destruction of property
arson
trump's tweeting about antifa and that
the white house will release vicious
dogs to go after protesters if they get
past the fence
oh and by the way the wall isn't being
built trump didn't repeal and replace
obamacare with something better like he
said he would
his trade war with china has failed 25
percent of the workforce is out of jobs
in the last 10 weeks
so of course donald trump is trying
trying to
take credit for spacex and make this
about antifa and otherwise pretend that
he's doing a great job
it is an abject failure that we have not
seen in the united states for a long
time and you have
you have to look at bush's failure on
911 when he said let's go into iraq even
though they didn't they didn't have
anything to do with the 911 attacks
and this is all meant to distract it
actually
is starting to feel like it may not work
if you look at polling
cautious optimism that what trump is
doing to distract isn't working
assume nothing every one of us has to
vote in november